bom dia a todos a mãe primeiro obrigada
obrigada por escolherem é estar sentados
hoje é nesta nesta sala é não resolvi
entrar vocês fizeram para assentados e
não escritos está sentado ruas nem todos
os dias da minha vida é não deixar 30
anos nas grandes que ainda assim é vida
corre sobre rodas dizer nos que ia te
dizer cruzaram se está a processar um
interface simples desculpa de honra joy
é trazer um ipad
a minha prioridade você estava em que há
algum tempo não muito nos ossos
um pequeno gesto influenciou o mundo
inteiro mais ou menos assim
acho mesmo que eu ia perder a
oportunidade de fazer uma self não bater
eu prometo novo time do cenário a viagem
é nenhum porque diz que não passar pelo
lyon dessas coisas é garantido diz que
ele é estar esse tio é um presente muito
muito muito reais para frente e ser uma
coisa chamada 18 minutos que dizem
cumprir
não vai ser tarefa fácil por isso mesmo
e não vou contar a história inteira da
minha vida porque senão teria 18 minutos
podem de fato problemas com as linhas ou
então se sentirem mais à vontade com a
história da conversa
isto faz podem falar comigo na amazônia
o meu pai enquanto alguns por aí e
ninguém melhor do que contar a história
da ilha é um tema que não é muito usual
as pessoas pensam algumas não é aquilo
que a vida dela há 30 anos sendo
portadora de não são não se não
precisarei do livro é falar com vocês
minha filha é o painel é mudar essa
impressão
fez lembrar é uma frase que eu gosto
muito
o quarto lugar é porque alguns
é na dele é que pra mim é uma eventual
china entendimento de que o processo
pedindo que nós podemos ter como grande
carga de terra
embora seja menor que todos os menus que
há na terra
contudo depois me auto press e torna se
a maior de todas as autorizações e daí
ter grande fã de seu pode usar as suas
ondas até então ser como a diferença as
palavras são sem licença ao menos ele
vinha dizendo uma palavra é palavra
favorita
obrigado a ter uma atitude de mudança e
que qualquer um de nós pode ser como um
grão de mostarda de nós é importante
pensar como eu não sou eu não estava lá
muito original ela tava vários fatos
imagine um cavalheiro também é dizermos
que é essencialmente está numa cadeira
rosa não é ou não tem se uma visão mais
negra por falta de cálcio
minha vida é é muito próxima daquilo que
é que não fui que quem é é um e isso
muda tudo
é para que no momento em que sentimos
que temos alguma coisa é vir aqui seja
sob circunstâncias é que haja um salto
agora é que eu seguir
eu não tinha que plantar é necessário
cortar e com o social e ter é a vontade
de não deixar essa é maior é minha e eu
considero a minha maior surpresa ao
longo de muito tempo que não não estava
à altura daquilo que eu era um exemplo
vida é uma forma como ela está num foi
adaptar às situações e de fato eu era
assim como o manual de instruções
o que aconteceu foi que nós temos muita
eficiência transformá-las apontada como
é e não como é que ela coitadinha
licença amazônica salvar-se para a
primeira divisão vai é nossa mentalidade
nela as pessoas fazem essa opção
queremos ter um grau de espargo é no
fundo o com grande história
estamos dispostos a conseguir olhar para
a vida
de gre nal uma atitude é de objetivo
final sem casa sem ver o óbvio ea minha
atenção
no fundo é constantemente pelo menos em
cursar em agradecer ao menos um pouco
porque é que vocês têm consciência é
muito maior do que isso é não depender
da empresa é rosa as coisas que não
posso fazer é pensar nas coisas que eu
já fiz aquilo que eu ainda vou fazer as
limitações não determinam os nossos
limites e nina comandar o bota vai ver é
dar mota frequentemente quando vai fazer
coisas tão radicais é que ele é
supostamente não deveriam ser muito
aconselhável alguém que está em ótimo
nível
ninguém vai é essencialmente que só será
assim não é capaz de chorar também não é
eu considero que nós não temos que ter
bons irmãos dias bons e ele mesmo se é
uma grande diferença quando conseguimos
olhar das pessoas é diferente nós na
aparência dar se a conhecer o que está
por trás de 97 centenas de pessoas
idosas é de ter uma aparência frágil
no fundo é era muito fácil
o episódio minha vida é meu amigo
próximo e também não é algo que eu que
não quero ter uma dieta de vista é que
fizemos aqui e sou muito flash mas ainda
eu quis partilhar com vocês nesse
momento
no final é aquilo que hoje é a minha
casa
os créditos nos obrigadas vírus é
organização é forma muito eficiente
disse que vai entregar aquilo que eu
considero que são alguns não todos os
meus obrigados a aceitar e fizesse o
mesmo
escrevo
genuinamente pra lá eu ia pra vocês
experimentam nervosa muito aqui e esse
que é roger disse que o pai em casa onde
possam de fato é olhar para os abrigados
nos dias menos bons
essa é maior ea atitude blasé a única
deficiência ea atitude negativa que
possui tudo ressaltou apenas problemas
muito muito obrigada a vocês